deutschland in der krise sie bekommen
selbst wahrscheinlich am besten mit ob
es die teuren preise an den tankstellen
sind beim einkaufen oder auch in
restaurants waren genauso teuer geht es
auch bei den heizkosten weiter deshalb
soll kohle jetzt erst einmal wieder
abhilfe schaffen wir hören mal was der
bundeskanzler dazu sagt denn was uns
nicht passieren darf das ist jetzt eine
globale renaissance der fossilen energie
und insbesondere der kurve hinein zu
schlittern niemand kann zufrieden sein
damit das auch bei uns der anteil der
kohleverstromung gerade wieder steigt
als reaktion auf drohende engpässe bei
der gasversorgung
umso wichtiger ist es dass wir eines
ganz klar festhalten
dass es eine zeitlich eng befristete
notmaßnahme die nicht zu lasten und soll
klimaziele geht
dasselbe gilt für investitionen in die
gas infrastruktur
zeitlich entschuldigung zeitlich eng
befristet aber wie lange heißt jetzt
schlussendlich eng befristet und was ist
jetzt mit den atomkraftwerken die
verbliebenen drei meiler sollen
eigentlich am 31 dezember am ende des
jahres abgeschaltet werden wie gesagt
eigentlich denn die rufe nach einer
laufzeitverlängerung werden immer lauter
atomkraftwerke pipelines strom und gas
wo kommt unsere energie her noch nie
wurden diese themen so heiß diskutiert
wie seit beginn des ukraine krieges fakt
ist fast 50 prozent der deutschen heizen
mit gas nur 14,1 prozent mit fernwärme
also die beheizung eines gebäudes mit
wärme aus einem kraftwerk heizwerk oder
einer müllverbrennung und 26 prozent der
deutschen heizen ihre vier wände mit
strom die deutschen wollen sich vor der
drohnen gas krise wappnen immer mehr
deutsche kaufen elektrische radiatoren
die über strom aus der steckdose eine
wohnung heizen heißt sobald die
temperaturen in deutschland fallen
steigt die nachfrage doch strom und gas
drei deutsche atomkraftwerke sind noch
in betrieb drei garanten für strom
allein im ersten quartal dieses jahres
wurden sechs prozent des stroms der
ostdeutschen steckdosen fließt aus
kernenergie gewonnen ein hohes gut in
deutschland eigentlich doch nicht mehr
lange geht es nach der spd und den
grünen denn die sind sich einig
pünktlich zum jahresende sollen in den
letzten drei deutschen atomkraftwerken
die lichter ausgehen
so wirtschaftsminister habeck vor knapp
einem monat in jordanien kernkraft passt
nicht zur grünen ideologie eine
glaubensfrage atomkraft nein danke doch
werden die atomkraftwerke jetzt
abgeschaltet muss dieser strom ersetzt
werden und dafür wird unter anderem das
so dringend benötigte gas benutzt damit
stellen sich spd und grüne gegen fdp und
opposition
wir verstehen nicht warum man eine
verlängerung der atomkraftwerke
insbesondere von den dreien die in
betrieb sind nicht vornehmen kann und
widersetzen sich dem wunsch der bürger
denn die deutschen werden immer ärmer
und fürchten den winter sie haben angst
vor klirrender kälte in den eigenen vier
wänden und unbezahlbaren
energierechnungen deswegen unser
vorschlag über den 31 dezember hinaus
die drei sicheren deutschen
kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen zu lassen um
eines zu erreichen dass kein einziger
kubikmeter gas denn dringen zu die
haushalte bringt für die industrie
benötigt wird dass der mäher verstromt
werden muss fordert fdp-fraktionschef
christian dürr bei bild live und
grünen-chefin ricarda lang deutet
sonntagabend eine atomkraftwerk werden
in krisen müsse man immer auf die
aktuelle situation reagieren und dabei
alle maßnahmen prüfen so die 28-jährige
ist dass die grüne atomkraft rolle
rückwärts weniger ideologien und dafür
mehr gas für deutschland
[Musik]
fakt ist immer mehr deutsche sind dafür
dass die atomkraftwerke weiterlaufen
eine aktuelle umfrage zeigt dass 63 das
für gut heißen mehr als die hälfte der
deutschen also und sogar bei den grünen
wählern sind es inzwischen 40 denn
atomkraftwerke könnten jetzt tatsächlich
teil der lösung sein für einen warmen
winter bei uns in deutschland und vor
allem auch für einen günstigeren winter
26 prozent der befragten sind weiterhin
gegen energie aus atomkraftwerken klar
fukushima tschernobyl
das hat man nicht vergessen das sind
dann immer wieder beispiele für die
gefahren die von der atomkraft ausgehen
können und schauen wir mal auf die
situation aktuell hier bei uns in
deutschland denn drei aktive standorte
für kernkraftwerke gibt es hierzulande
noch ein akw ist an der isar hier sehen
wir jetzt unsere karte ein anderes dann
in neckarwestheim und auch im emsland
stehen zwei akw s mit atomfabrik in
lingen und genau dort in lingen im
emsland beim akw steht jetzt unsere bild
reporterin annika rasch anleger die
bundesregierung ist trotz des ukraine
krieges von ihrer entscheidung eben noch
nicht abgewichen die akw laufzeit zu
verlängern nun hat sich aber diese woche
was getan was genau
genau diese also wir stehen jetzt hier
vor dem einen der drei akw s die eben
noch in betrieb sind im emsland und der
entscheidende satz der diese woche
gefallen ist ist wir rechnen jetzt
nochmal und dieser satz kommt
ausgerechnet von den grünen die sich
lange weigerte neben über diese
verlängerte laufzeit der akw s zu
verhandeln jetzt sagte aber die
sprecherin airbags dass man nun einen
zweiten stresstest durchführen möchte
das heißt man möchte schauen ob man
diese akw länger laufen lässt oder ob
die strom
stromversorgung gesichert ist über den
winter und mit den ergebnissen wird in
den nächsten wochen gerechnet also das
ist ein sehr historischer satz wir
rechnen jetzt nochmal denn bisher schien
es wirklich unmöglich dass die grünen
einer verlängerung zustimmen würden und
nun scheint sich die lage ein bisschen
zu ändern und ja ein bisschen bewegung
rein zu kommen denn ja es wäre so
historisch wenn ausgerechnet die grünen
am ende sagen wir müssen die akw länger
am laufen halten wie sieht es denn
generell aus mit dem akw emsland direkt
hinter dir arbeitet das noch
genau das akw emsland hier hinter mir
ihr seht auch wenn wir mal ein bisschen
schwenken diese runde kuppel darunter
ist der reaktor dieses akw wurde 1988 in
betrieb genommen und produziert jährlich
elf milliarden kilowattstunden strom
das reicht für ungefähr 3,5 millionen
haushalte und ab ende des jahres soll
eben auch dieses akw heruntergefahren
wie werden wie eben auch die anderen 2
vielen dank an die garage live aus dem
emsland
dankeschön bundesregierung und
opposition suchen nach kurz und
langfristigen lösungen aus der
energiekrise
die union kommt jetzt mit einem sehr
speziellen vorschlag um die ecke sie
will eine akw-laufzeitverlängerung
verknüpfen mit einem tempolimit auf
autobahnen
aber sowohl die grünen als auch die fdp
müssten dafür interne rote linien
überschreiten den grünen würde es ja
natürlich weh tun wenn sie die
laufzeiten der drei akw verlängern
müssten und der fdp würde ein tempolimit
auf autobahnen natürlich gar nicht
schmecken für die union könnte daraus
ein nationaler kompromiss werden doch
die liberalen wollen sich eigentlich
nicht auf diesen kuhhandel einlassen wir
sind jetzt wird boris palmer verbunden
oberbürgermeister von tübingen mit einer
mitgliedschaft bei den grünen hallo herr
palmer wie schauen sie auf diesen
möglichen kuhhandel innerhalb der ampel
regierung verlängerung der
akw-laufzeiten gegen ein tempolimit auf
autobahnen wäre das eine möglichkeit
also erstmal scheuch pragmatisch drauf
wenn es was bin um gut durch den winter
zu kommen und die gaskrise zum beispiel
dann darf nichts tabu sein aber der
kuhhandel hat den nachteil dass bei
dinge verknüpft die halt nicht so viel
bringen also gefahren wird bei uns ja
nicht mit gas oder mit öl das ist nicht
das problem
also ist das tempolimit gutes klima aber
eigentlich keine lösung der gaskrise und
auch bei den akw es ist so dass die ich
nicht gebraucht werden um durch den
winter zu kommen wir haben gegen
kohlekraftwerke die das leisten können
wir sollten darüber reden wir jetzt gas
sparen da wundert es mich dass die
geister strom um den ganzen sommer läuft
ohne dass da irgendwas gemacht hat das
hätte man schon lang abstellen können
also kurze antwort wir machen
politisches symbol debatten und kümmern
uns nicht um die wirklich wichtigen und
richtigen maßnahmen wenn wir weniger gas
verbrauchen wollen müssen wir uns
zwischen den beiden alternativen
entscheiden kohle oder atomkraft wie
stehen sie zu diesen beiden alternativen
das ist mir diesen winter ehrlich gesagt
nicht wichtig entscheidend ist dass die
industrie nicht abgeschaltet werden muss
dass wir unsere produzierenden betrieben
nicht verlieren und dass die immer gas
zur verfügung haben wir wie man das
erreicht und darüber kann man sprechen
es kann aus drei monate länger atomkraft
laufzeit sein wenn etwas bringen würde
aber fürs klima sind die treiben unter
dem meer mit kohle auch nicht wichtig es
geht um den langfristigen ausstiegen ich
habe den nächsten winter aber wie würden
sie es dann machen dass es im winter
nicht kalt wird was ist ihre lösung
dafür
ich würde sagen die temperatur in allen
öffentlichen gebäuden um drei grad
runter den linda die privaten
verbraucher auch bitten dass wenigstens
zwei grad runter gehen wo die
stromversorgung strom die gasverstromung
beenden wir haben in tübingen und
fernwärmenetzes vollständig mit gas
betrieben wird dann monaten sage ich
ihnen könnten das sofort auf öl
umstellen ist kostet aber was nur bild
niemand diesen mehr preis bezahlen
obwohl das volkswirtschaftlich villiger
sie nicht das gas jetzt aus den
speichern zu nehmen ist das reinste
punkten um im winter besser
durchzukommen und die industrie am
laufen zu halten solche maßnahmen könnte
man ergreifen aber ich warte darauf
bisher leider vergeblich robert habeck
sagt jetzt wir rechnen noch mal sogar 40
prozent der grünen wähler sind für eine
akw laufzeitverlängerung
sind die grünen jetzt tatsächlich bereit
sich von ihren dogmen zu trennen wie
sieht das aus wie
wahrscheinlich sind die grünen insgesamt
viel pragmatischer als das in mancher
berichterstattung aussieht was mich
angeht sowieso wie gesagt 300 lkw es um
durch den winter zu kommen macht mir gar
nichts wenn es technisch geht und was
bringt aber ich halte nicht für den
entscheidenden baustein
wir können die stromerzeugung
sicherstellen auch ohne akw es darum
geht es eigentlich nicht wir müssen gas
sparen gerne möchten mit ihnen noch über
die inflation sprechen deutschland in
der krise müssen löhne von der regierung
und auch von der eu aufgestockt werden
um diese inflation auszugleichen oder
anzugleichen
leider hab ich ihre frage wusste ich
nicht gehört aber nicht ob ich um
zum thema inflation müssen die löhne von
der regierung und von der eu aufgestockt
werden für die bürger damit sie sich ihr
leben noch leisten können
nein ich glaube nicht dass wir dauerhaft
die kosten dieser krisen durch den staat
ausgleichen können irgendwann ist er
nicht mehr zahlungsfähig
wir müssen eher mal darüber nachdenken
ob es sich vielleicht lohnt eine stunde
mehr zu arbeiten immer weitere
arbeitszeitverkürzung in der
arbeitskräftemangel frei einkommen zum
leben da gibt es eine naheliegende
lösung man arbeitet werden hat man
wieder mehr geld im geld wollten oder
sind aber keine schönen aussichten für
die bürger länger arbeiten und trotzdem
eben dann das gleiche letztendlich im
portemonnaie haben vielen dank boris
palmer nach tübingen
dagegen